as the left attempts to finish the
umayyad caliphates job at the Battle of
Tours by dismantling the Western
civilization we hold so dear
while the alt-right tries to make it a
matter of melanin we ask classicist
scholar and immortal heir to the
multiverse spencer Clavin a simple
question what is the West then lone
conservative Cassie Dillon and flex
talks joined to discuss president
Trump's congressional Smackdown
Florida's finally killing white guys who
kill black guys and the Girl Scouts
outraged that the Boy Scouts are
becoming the Girl Scouts how transphobic
are they plus the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
Western civilization is all the rage
these days a hot topic of debate here is
Tucker Carlson and president Trump
describing Western civilization Tucker
on his show and President Trump in his
warsaw address President Trump's speech
in Poland last week may have been the
single best thing he has set out laughs
since entering politics and for one
reason
it was a rousing defense of Western
civilization we write symphonies we
pursue innovation we celebrate our
ancient heroes embrace our timeless
traditions and customs and always seek
to explore and discover brand new
frontiers the fundamental question of
our time is whether the West has the
will to survive do we have the
confidence in our values to defend them
at any cost that's a very good question
the left hopes the answer to that
question is no they have at least since
the time of Jesse Jackson marching on
college campuses said hey hey ho ho
Western Civ has got to go here's why
that triggered the alarm bells for me am
I wrong in making this parallel between
Steve King president Trump and white
nationalism Trump seemed to embody and
enshrine that belief that the West
shouldn't steal itself for clash of
civilizations with other cultures other
beliefs which pretty much spelled out
you know the Muslim world so this is not
a speech he could have given really any
place else and this is a white America
America first kind of speech well as he
talks on the Left about white
nationalists let's ask a white
nationalist himself Richard Spencer and
the late Sam Francis also get in on the
battle to define Western civilization a
quotation from Samuel Francis is from
the mid 90s and he actually said this at
a speech at an American Renaissance
conference he said the civilization that
we as whites created in Europe and
America could not have developed apart
from the genetic endowment of the
creating people nor is there any reason
to believe that the civilization can be
successfully transmitted to a different
people whether you're on the left or the
right many people seem to imagine that
we could just find a you know a black
African and dress him up in a Harris
tweed vest or give them a pipe or some
snuff and maybe a bowler cap and he'll
become an Englishman or something like
that
or you know in another way like the
neo-cons we describe Western
civilization in this totally abstract
term where it's you know some vague
ideas about individualism and political
institutions like democracy and so on
Steve King is not doing that now they
all seem to get this wrong all of those
people and that is why last week we
talked to a Charlottesville unites the
right attendee about the alt-right and
how they define Western civilization and
today we're joined by an in-studio guest
Spencer Clavin a classicist and
obviously heir to the to the multiverse
now I can't help but notice Spencer
Clavin is here I can't help but notice
the coincidence of the name are you
related to Richard Spencer you know not
genetically and as I understand it
that's basically the only kind of
relationship they acknowledge so I would
have to say no I'm not not genetically
certainly not spiritually it doesn't
exist Spencer a very simple question
what is the West
boy oh boy you know it's funny I one of
my great regrets as a doctoral student
is that I don't get to spend a lot of
time firing up the old tor browser and
you know only when you're buying
contract killings and drugs I assume no
sir I marshal will cut it out right
you'll cut out how spencer Clavin
engages in contract let's turn up the
audio on that part ok good thanks
we wouldn't want that to get out is it
is it too late for me to cover my look I
mean I'm not up on the whole heck and
Pepe the Frog of it all so I might be
getting some of this but it seems to me
whenever I listen to the alright on this
stuff I'm amazed at how exactly like the
radical progressive left they sound I
mean basically Richard Spencer is
basically at the point of accusing
people of cultural appropriation which
I'm pretty sure with was the province
Sol
of the you know the far left but on this
particular point I think that the the
radical progressive left and the
alt-right are almost in exact complete
agreement I mean you have the alt-right
chanting things like blood and soil and
soil right which amounts to the
assertion that basically what it is to
be Western is to be born into a certain
gene pool within a certain set of
Geographic barriers and that's basically
what a lot of people on the Left want to
claim is true of Western civilization
that all of our lofty ideals and
principles are essentially just window
dressing for a kind of white supremacy
right I mean this is back in I think
there's a 1978 Edward Sayyid basically
makes this argument Orientalism that
it's all kind of a Western identity is
just a way of justifying to oneself the
superiority of whites white people your
18 countries right exactly um I take a
slightly different view on the subject
by which I mean basically the exact
opposite slightly 180 degrees a it'd be
just like a slight turn to everything
that is not that and you'll get what I
think I mean look one of the crowning
achievements of actual Western
civilization is to develop slowly over
time and space this idea of a nation
hood whose citizenship doesn't depend on
ethnic or Geographic determiners I mean
you really I think this really kind of
you can see it beginning with the Stoics
who you know the ancient Greek said of
ancient philosophers and the Stoics had
this idea which exists before then but
which they developed in a really robust
way of the law GaAs right the law goes
being this universal sort of rational
principle or rationality that pervades
the whole universe that and things like
ideas about you know right and wrong and
logic those all come under the head of
this law goes which exists everywhere
and that's kind of where you start to
get this idea or to justify this idea
that there might be a universal
civilization being is you could have a
society of people who no matter where
they are or what race they were they
live by the law goes long as there's an
eternal law and eternal reason exactly
that isn't confined
to your government right and you see
this again it plays out elsewhere like
Cicero near the end of the of the Roman
Republic he writes that on the Republic
and he talks about a law that will not
be different at a different time or a
different place and different in Athens
and in Rome but it'll be the same for
everyone and that law is justice this
idea of you know of right and wrong and
good and bad that kind of pervades the
whole universe and so again that you
start to develop that idea of a society
that that transcends location and space
until you know a minor event occurs in
the Middle East around oh I don't know
the Year Zero
that's so incidence right now one time
stored it's amazing that's it yeah Jesus
Christ is born and one of the claims
that use Christ I think makes about
himself and it certainly made about him
is that he is the law goes as it as a
human being right that that the word the
law Gus was made flesh and so now you
have a person claiming to actually
pronounce the universal moral law and
and as as Christ himself says you know
allegiance to him is what defines
membership in the universal society
right whoever does the will of God that
is my brother or my mother or my sister
my kingdom is not of this world meaning
it's not in a specific time replace and
so out of that tradition then you get
people like Agustin whom start to kind
of theologizing to Christianize the
Ciceronian idea of a universal
civilization thank you Christ even goes
further he says if you don't hate your
mother and your brother and your sister
then you can't follow him if you don't
renounce your parochial and superficial
bonds then you can never bond yourself
with the logos with the eternal law yeah
I mean I really think there he's he's
almost building on the call of Abraham
way back in in Genesis right God says to
Abraham leave your your home and your
brothers and your father and everything
that you've known and be defined by my
call to you be defined by what God
pronounces as truth and you know
actually it's Paul too confronted the
the Stoics and the Epicureans in it in
the in acts and you usually kind of read
this as an adversarial confrontation
between Christianity and Greek
philosophy basically I mean Paul quotes
aratus at them who had strong stoic
roots so basically what he's saying is
look you Greeks you Greek philosophers
you already believe this you already
believe in this universal Society I'm
telling you that the king of that
society was here on earth in a
particular person and so then that gets
fed into the Christian tradition with
with Agustin and with Aquinas so it
which is effectively this massive major
strain of Western thought is the
opposite of blood and soil it's the only
idea that really effectively contravenes
what everyone else believes you know
which is which is that you are in a
particular place and time and genetic
material and that's what makes you who
you are I think you just made all the
all right guys heads explode I think
because for most of those guys I think I
think they read a summary one time
excerpt of the spake Zarathustra a bell
curve I think that's basically the Canon
of this great thinkers well we were
talking before the show about you know
analyzing the portion of Aristotle where
he quotes the bell curve that's right I
remember you know the Greek better than
I do I do remember in Aristotle he often
expands upon how we must secure the
existence of our people in the future
for white children did I get the
translation wrong mmm you know that's
actually that's book it's a lost book it
didn't get transmitted over but but the
alt-right has a secret code that allows
them to read the mind so you know I read
on them I guess that's the sake Vox
Populi or whatever yeah yeah
incidentally I think you know the it
seems like a seminal feature of all
right discourses is like purposefully
misspelling words words and ideas which
goes really well with the willful
misunderstanding of crucial concepts but
anyway I read on Vox Populi this this
assertion that you know if only the
founders had kept the title of the
rights of Englishmen instead of using
the concept of natural law for
propagandistic purposes so it's like oh
it's it's a living document we know what
was really there you know if it really
meant they could write it today so
you're telling me that you trace the
West to Jews and gay guys and this by
the way they are going to call us cucks
that is going to be in the comments
action my question for you about that if
an alt writer calls a gay guy a [ __ ]
mm-hmm does that mean that there's an
alt writer out there somewhere sleeping
with a guy this is this is the kleavon's
theorem Spencer Clavin steer this is
going to become a major question or all
right thinkers a paradox of sorts and
that's that is really good
so you think I will I will push back a
little bit okay is there no Geographic
component where these ideas not carried
by people as specific people and
specific times and places
no you make a really good point I mean
before sort of the stoic philosophy that
I was talking about you have people like
Aristotle who expressly tie the whole
ethical universe to the paulus to this
particular city in which you're living
in and there is another important strand
of Western thought that you have to kind
of incorporate we talked about this
which is sort of development of the idea
of the nation-state as as kind of the
Goldilocks of political entities right
the big enough guys about ready likely
the right size to defend the individual
liberty in in the real world but the
thing about that is you know that
acknowledges a fact about the world
which is that we live in countries and
related to people and have ties to this
particular life but the whole project of
the West I would argue maybe even a
definitive project of the West is the
struggle over you know centuries to
reconcile that fact with this beautiful
notion of the universal Society and
basically I think what people come up
with is this concept that your
particular nation might somehow embody
or be a model of the universal Society
this this comes up a lot in Aquinas but
you know where it really comes up is in
the idea for America John Winthrop jail
of Christian Sheriff and I know talk
about making the all rights head explode
the concept of a creedal nation is like
you know anatomized
but that that the founders read their
Cicero they read their Bible that this
is a concept that was not alien to them
and essentially the whole idea is to
unify the
the nation state with the idea of the
universal society and get a country to
whom you can belong in which you can be
a citizen solely by in the ideal world
solely by ascribing or professing fealty
to a certain series of ideas life
liberty liberty equality under the law
pursuit of property private property
that's right shooting shooting people at
will there somewhere oh no I'm sorry
you're not right yeah it's in this in
some attending the right now nationalism
has come to the fore as a response to
Davos basically is a response to these
globalized elites who want to get rid of
many features of the nations today and
so we have a robust defense of
nationalism we have a robust defense of
Western civilization and it seems that
those defenses are often totally missing
the point of the nation and of the
Western civilization how do we defend it
how do we pick up like our forefathers
and Philadelphia did how do we pick up
Cicero and bring our civilization into
its next phase into the future and to
preserve our country well you know a
good start would be to actually read I
want to certainly read much more than I
have written that is but I all in all I
don't I don't want to watch youtube
videos I don't want to read these things
right sorry okay subscribe better that's
creative actually I'm actually reading
the Canon look you know this is a thing
as I'm sure will shortly discover on the
panel you know my job is basically to
sit in dusty attics lined with books and
read about people from 2,000 years ago
so I basically digest information at
like a 2,000 year delay so so when you
get down to sort of I I'm hoping that
people like you can answer the question
of how do we put these ideas into
practice in the modern world I will say
this it's not through nostalgia this
idea that you know we're going to
basically resurrect the Ciceronian or
the Aristotelian or any number of
ancient ideals by living the life that
Cicero or or Aristotle lived by throwing
our iPhones away
and you know living according to this
the this is gonna live in court of a
sexual morality of 300 years ago right
that's just that just doesn't happen
that's not how the how the world works
what I think we have to do is you know
another kind of Aristotelian ideas want
to form and matter right that you have
the particular form the regular matter
in which things are embodied but then
you have the the concepts and the ideas
which as we've been talking about are
universal I support and I think what we
really have to do is figure out how to
embody the ideals that we've been
talking around in the 21st century given
all of the new facts that are available
to us and you bring up an interesting
point on academics on the elites you
it's it I think the guys who are Western
chauvinists and who are basically white
identitarian 's they try to pride
themselves on being intellectually
superior you know they read the bell
curve or part of it and they think they
have a high IQ and that they've read but
they don't really know anything about
their civilization you have read all the
books thank you what is the role of
elites in conservatism
and in America they've gotten a bad rap
over the last year and a half there's
been a revolt in many ways against the
elites how do we how do we use them what
is the role of an elite yeah this is
really nice to sweat under the collar
torn feather you that's right you his
doctorate in classics it's like it
doesn't get more a kind of like every
fairy was it you got rejected from
Gender Studies is that why you had to
choose classics you know I did I give
them my best but I wasn't quite queer
enough one degree for that no um I I I
do think that the some of the criticism
that have been leveled with the elites
are partially justified in the sense
that in this country we have become we
being the started a set name reach easy
intellectual elites we have become
disconnected from the basic everyday
concerns the animate 90% of the
population and I think that the
elections on from as evidence of that
but how the fact of how shocked I was by
the number of people who sympathize with
man that I
find abhorrent it tells me that there's
something going on I'm not keyed into or
at least there was and I'm trying out it
I have a metaphor about this he which
will take me a second but bear witness
so so my mom has a plumber that she
likes to call whatever our toilet breaks
down which is approximately every five
minutes yeah and the plumber is always
boring her with these long descriptions
of the technical process that he's gonna
undergo to fix her toilet you know
widgets and gaskets are I'm not just
saying words yeah I have no idea about
any other words other than plunger I
didn't if I yeah if I listened to the
plumber I would know but hey um my mom's
joke is always you know I I pay you to
know about these things I'm really glad
that I don't have so that I don't have
to right exactly so that's fine if the
plumber then were to go off and come
back and say you know in my deep study
of plumbing theory in my extensive
analysis of widgets gaskets and what
have you I have discovered that actually
what a toilet is supposed to do is not
flush human waste into the sewage but
actually regurgitate it up into your
face every time you flush it that's what
the true purpose of a toilet is then the
authority to say no actually that's not
what those would rest with my mom
because she uses the toilet every day
and she knows what it's there for it's
there to serve me likewise the general
populace doesn't actually you know
they're not required to and nor are many
of them interested to sort of delve into
the high weeds of political and
philosophical and now historical that's
right I mean it's not incumbent upon
every citizen to study to the degree
that you know required to get a PhD and
we do we have elites for that so that
they can you know study the theory
behind these things and bring it back to
us and essentially they'll just breathe
dust for the rest of their lives look
exactly issue human interaction the
entire adult lives anyway no I mean so
that they can come back and offer to us
things that we maybe didn't know and
guide us in ways that we might not have
any of
to do but if what they bring back to us
is at odds with what we know to be true
in our own life and experience then we
do have we being the sort of general
population we do have some authority to
say no actually that's not what the
state is for that's not what these
because we encounter and we can tell I
can't tell if it's working or if it
isn't working
if GDP growth never rises above 3% or
whatever it was no argument in the world
is going to convince the person the
hungry person that we have the right
political philosophy and play in some
abstract sense so there has to be a kind
of dialogue and interaction and the fact
that the elites have kind of absconded
on that dialogue and declared their
authority to be absolute is the problem
it's not that they are elites at all
that is an excellent analogy it it rings
so true because when I think of the
so-called elites the elites like in the
media like George Stephanopoulos you
know the elites that most of our
universities the image that comes to
mind is a bad plumber spewing excrement
my face that is a wonderful analogy and
on that I think we have to bring in our
panel we have a superb panel of
deplorable --zz today we have Spencer's
going to stick around we have caste
Dylan and we have flex talks you guys
want to come in they're all in the
studio today I've summoned them all to
this lair the broom closet of the Ben
Shapiro show because we because we have
to talk more about Western civilization
like us you've just gotten an image of
University Professors spewing excrement
near face
does it ring true you were in college
pretty recently hayflick guys why don't
you go ahead and share a mic with a with
Michael on the desk that way you guys
serve but both making the same thing up
your mic just went out all right
actually it's fair that he gets to share
it with you because today is Austin's
birthday hey happy birthday my kiss
talks what an honor to have him
all right well if like as you bring up
these Dartmouth professors there was
this guy Mark Bray I think his name is a
Dartmouth professor who was on defending
antifa
the other day and defending the violent
left suppressing free thought how did
these guys get jobs there uh I don't
know that's a good question but I think
if they weren't getting jobs you know
the majority of the professor's are on
the same page so it's probably easier
for them to get jobs and keep their jobs
and to bring on someone with more
conservative views and at least we're
keeping them off the streets if this guy
professor Bray weren't there he just
it's a nice Criminal Employment Program
isn't it oh yeah and I saw the I saw
that piece you're talking about you know
defending and Tifa and these Antipa
people think they're out there fighting
the Nazis they think there really are
not there's a huge Nazi problem in the
US and we need them to step up take it
to the streets get violent justified
violence and defeat the Nazis on you
know for America as if there are heroes
that's there's a lot of projection going
on I think on their part
Kassie we've been talking about the
centrality of logos of Greek thought and
Jerusalem of Christianity that built the
West these days in the West people don't
think and they don't practice any
religion if any of any classical variety
do you think I know young people very
often are not raised in formal religious
households anymore though there is a
little pushback to that do you think
that there's a future for the right or
for Western civilization if it remains
atheistic reset Euler is there a way to
translate those classical religious
values into secularism or do we all need
to get back to church and synagogue and
get some old-time religion I found that
to be a very difficult question because
if you look at Europe it's becoming
progressively less religious but if you
look at certain parts of America it's
actually becoming more religious and I
think that has to do with a lot of
values changing in American society
where people are confused and kind of
scared of what's going on so they're
going back to the church which gives
them the foundation for beliefs that
they have held true throughout the last
couple hundred years so even in the West
I would say that secularism is becoming
or in the East secularism is coming more
prominent too in certain areas but you
are seeing the rise of more
fundamentalist around the world
so I think that you need to have the
clear balance if you aren't getting your
values from religion you have to figure
out where are you getting them from Al
Gore environmentalism I came I get
anything from the Internet
I guess we're fixing flexes microphone
I'm just making sure no one's
manspreading yeah take this moment to
ensure it is the Michael note show we
defend your right to spread your legs as
far as you want gentlemen so we so we
have to get to the news before we kick
out all of the people who haven't
subscribed we have to talk about the
most important story in the headlines
today the Boy Scouts are becoming the
Girl Scouts and the Girl Scouts are very
upset about this the Girl Scout
president just sent a letter to the Boy
Scout president saying quote I formally
request that your organization's stay
focused on serving the 90% of American
boys not currently participating in Boy
Scouts ouch what a burn it is unsettling
that the Boy Scouts of America would
seek to upend a paradigm that has served
both boys and girls so well through the
years Cassie as our resident female why
are the boys that's recruiting girls but
this isn't just transgender transgender
issues they're recruiting girls just
actual girls okay so I think I have a
little bit of authority to speak on this
I go to an all-girls school the first
all-girls school in America Mount
Holyoke so I when you have women in a
space that's just women whether it's
just women in Outlook anymore who knows
but I think you have people women coming
together and actually getting a voice
because it is true that women don't
speak as much in class I have seen it
when I'm in that holy classes even the
women don't talk it's like just me and
the random man who's visiting in the
class but I think when you have women
together in a space it does give them
some sense of becoming stronger woman
because I think the best way to get
women to raise is how to do it
themselves no don't knock down men why
would people do that so I think that the
Boy Scouts are trying to be inclusive
and by doing this they're actually
targeting women in there they're
wrecking your feminism whatever they
want to call it but I think it's just
it's not okay and I think you're gonna
see a rise in a tension between the two
organizations
brings up a really weird tension that we
see throughout the modern left Spencer
some say the world will end in feminism
some say in transgender movement afire
rice or something who is to blame here
and how will the left be able to resolve
this tension between a feminism that
says women should have their own
organization and should be able to do
whatever men want to do and a
transgender gender bender movement in
the popular culture that says men and
women are essentially the same and those
categories are mutable and we can will
our way from one to the other I think
this is this is one of those issues on
which you know we need to find our way
forward incorporating new information
that would be better that has actually
come to us since since we sort of set up
the paradigms that are reflected in say
the boys and the Girl Scouts it is true
and I think you actually see this in
leftist discourse it is true that there
is a there's a tension between the idea
that there is no difference between the
genders it's purely physical situation
and and that someone could somehow it
could be spiritually one gender and
physically another personally I'm I'm
sympathetic to the latter claim but not
really to the former and I think that
that's probably the idea that that has
to go it seems just deeply it's one of
those ideas that is deeply contradictory
to the evidence of our basic experience
you know there to be two genders we know
that they have a spiritual component as
well as a physical component right and
and that basically speaking there are
some indiscernible whether they call
them population-level all right
differences between men and women I also
actually believe that it is you know
that you encounter people who have a
tension between those two aspects of
their certainly necessary yeah no I mean
absolutely and so I think you know we
need to find a compassionate and
charitable way to incorporate that new
fact into our idea that the genders are
actually different right that the left
one of those will win and we need to
make sure that it's compassionate and
not totally not totally ignorant of
physical realities not ignorant of
social realities either
I have one more question before we say
goodbye to Facebook I'm giving them a
little something extra today Marshall we
have Lucas one of these reasons for the
Boy Scouts to start recruiting women and
young girls is that some girls want to
do adventurous stuff the Boy Scouts go
camping and do adventurous stuff the
Girl Scouts sell delicious cookies that
I buy every year so what is the problem
with having a tomboyish girl join the
Boy Scouts if she doesn't want to just
sit around and sell cookies there is a
problem that necessarily but I think
maybe the Girl Scouts should do a little
bit of a rebrand and you know get away
from the cookie selling I'm gonna cut
you off right there how dare you the
Girl Scouts stop selling those cookies
we will not stand for that I make sure
the cookies keep coming but maybe a
little bit a rebrand and get up with the
times a little bit and you know have
more adventurous things and do more you
know tomboy or stuff whatever you want
to call it instead of you know combining
the two because they already called the
Boy Scouts it's kind of a tough rebrand
for the Boy Scouts fair enough now we
will say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
if you are already a subscriber thank
you thank you for supporting this show
keeping the lights on allowing me to
purchase Girl Scout cookies if you are
not go to daily wire comm right now it
is $10 a month one hundred dollars a
year you get my show you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
but who cares about any of that you get
the leftist tears tumblr the most
sought-after piece of material on earth
it keeps your leftist ears hot or cold
always salty and delicious and those
tears are flowing these days after that
Phoenix speech it's it seemed that they
were falling out of the sky so make sure
you go over there you get your leftist
here's tumblr so you can catch them and
imbibe them and dream and carouse on
their intoxicating deliciousness daily
wire.com go over there right now we'll
be right back
[Music]
all right in today's tweet news there's
always some president Trump tweet news
president Trump is once again tweeting
his displeasure with Mitch McConnell and
Paul Ryan he tweeted at just today quote
I requested that Mitch M and Paul r tie
the debt ceiling legislation into the
popular VA bill which just passed for
easy approval they didn't do it so now
we have a big deal with Dems holding
them up as usual on debt ceiling
approval could have been so easy now a
mess and another quote came out the only
problem I have with Mitch McConnell is
that after hearing repeal and replace
for seven years he failed that never
should have happened
I am inflecting my voice up to Express
the exclamation points fly kisses Trump
right um I think yeah I'm cool with it I
think this is a I think this is a great
way to call someone out obviously with
Trump in the White House it's not
business as usual it's not politics as
it used to be but he is a you know
businessman he's got a business mind and
this is something I saw in football too
I played football in college and if
you're not bringing it if you're not
performing if you're not going 110
percent the coach calls you out in front
of the whole team and it kind of did
with Jeff Sessions a few weeks back and
I think since then and things have
gotten better he's back in his good
graces so I think yeah it's not politics
as usual but the change is the change
that people voted for because a lot of
people especially in the media are
whining that President Trump isn't
handling this in private conversations
and whispering to them and I guarantee
you none of those people have ever
picked up a football you're saying
there's a benefit to being called out in
public holding people accountable making
them sweat a little bit and hopefully
straightening out their job yeah exactly
and where it's kind of keep saying
rebrand today but I think what it means
to be President it's changing like you
know a few years back we could have
watched Obama and said Oh Obama's great
he gave really passionate speeches you
could tell he cared you know he's a
really good orator he's our guy but then
there's a lot of things behind the
scenes that I don't think he did very
well so like everything yeah everything
was one of those things that he didn't
do very well yeah so you know you have
to kind of treat Trump you know for what
he is he's just a different guy he's not
a pun you know your standard politician
and with that there are so
benefits and I think that's what the
people voted for Cassie why has the
congressional leadership not been able
to round up these votes is it because
they don't have confidence in Trump or
is the GOP just hopelessly fractured
honestly it's the never Trump burgers
you can blame lovely man the never Trump
worship well they aren't working with
him at all and instead of going with the
Republican Party they're worried the
Democrats and it's just really hard to
anything past and if you saw in the
speech he was throwing a lot of shade at
John McCain I didn't hear him name
anybody I think he said there was one
senator just one your senator yes I
think it's definitely telling but I do
think that Trump is going and they
attacked you soon we have a long session
left and honestly if he keeps doing this
are they gonna work with him in the
future I think so more things we've done
behind closed doors and I don't know
things have been necessarily but I think
going in the offense this early on it
can be dangerous well yeah some things
can be done behind closed doors like
funding Jeff Lakes primary opponents and
the others not a bad idea Spencer does
this help president Trump boy oh boy I
just you know so often with Trump it's
like vaguely kind of the shape of
something you might want him to be doing
and then like substance like that it's
really insane so I mean it we've seen
that he has trouble working with the
legislature we've seen that he has
trouble marshaling people behind his his
idea is to get bills passed and I
suppose that then you would probably
want him to be able to develop a set of
techniques for convincing or or
corralling as they say the the the
legislature into his camp but the idea
that you're gonna pass the debt ceiling
by tying it to a VA bill is like you're
gonna sneak a nuclear bomb into the
Pentagon by tying it to a king right
like there's just in what unit idea in
what universe would you have would that
have been an effective plan so I don't
know it's as usual I kind of throw up my
hands that is fair every time I'm asked
to say will this help Trump will this
hurt Trump I'm always wrong inevitably I
don't know what and what answer I give
but I'm always wrong because nobody can
predict this guy nobody can ever tell
what Trump is going to do which
why I got $400 from my friend mr.
Shapiro okay for the first time in
Florida's modern history a white man has
received the death penalty for killing a
black man and this seems like progress
to me seems like a a wonderful move for
social justice Cassie is it a win for
social justice and racial equality
honestly I think it's a it's a big deal
but necessarily it's not really that big
of a deal because this was gonna make it
what the 80s and this isn't the first
white man who's been killed for what's
the first one in Florida and only reason
why were talking about it because the
Charlottesville
if the Charlottesville didn't happen we
would not be talking about this I don't
think it's a necessarily the biggest
news topic that we may be talking about
right now with the only reason why we're
talking about is concerns though and we
also need to acknowledge that this is a
bigger deal not because of the skin
color of the person but because this is
after they changed the laws regarding
execution in Florida right extreme court
talks about it right and a lot of
opposition to it you always hear
opposition to the death penalty because
of racial disparities a lot more black
guys or getting the death penalty for
committing murder than white people and
there are a number of theories as to why
that is but deep down it appears to me
this is all just about opposition to the
death penalty per se you've got people
coming out today with this story saying
this doesn't change the hundreds of
years without executing a white man for
killing a black man and we need to get
rid of it altogether
Spencer hanging concentrates the mind
wonderfully yet nobody ever talks about
these spiritual and political benefits
of capital punishment is there a place
for the death penalty in our society
right now man I have just been reading
Bowie yes it was basically right and
he's writes his entire you know his
great contribution to philosophy has
written sort of under pain of death so I
guess at the moment I'm more sympathetic
a philosophic to the death penalty you
know exactly I mean this is one of those
issues you know if you needed a hot take
on Aristotelian hila morphism by the way
for one my whole life I've realized yeah
but I feel sure on this question that
I'm likely to put my foot in my mouth no
matter what I say I will say that you
know the death penalty is a for me at
least a deeply complex and conflicted if
you morally because it's both a concept
and abstracted concentration should put
people to death for certainly crimes
that are so heinous they you know that
pragmatically we need to remove them but
it's also a historic policy enacted in
time and space
and I think in that in that respect in
America it's it's a deeply troubled
because it's not always applied fairly
these days right everybody gets it but
nobody is actually executed people sit
on death row forever and ever it's like
it seems cruel and unusual in many ways
yeah that's it that's sort of what I
mean you know those those kinds of
particulars of the death penalty as
practice here in America you you can't
ignore when you have this conversation
they certainly muddy the waters of the
kind of more more abstract question is
the death penalty ever okay and and for
certain crimes it's very complex as to
whether they would could warrant the
death penalty and for some like
suggesting that we get rid of Girl Scout
cookies the answer is very curious
birthday boy very clear okay I have got
to say goodbye to my excellent panel of
deplorable --zz we have Austin Fletcher
flex talks loan conservative Cassie
Dylan and what's his name Spencer Clavin
classicist and heir to the multiverse
thank you all for being here now it is
time for the mailbag so we had a lot of
mailbag questions today we're gonna burn
through them from John mr. trolls I'm a
student at Wofford College and after
reading your book several times I'm
hungry for more wisdom smart man would
you be interested in coming to our
campus to speak I would love to come to
your campus to speak shoot me a tweet or
something or send an email in and we'll
set it up I love doing them from Teresa
hey Michael how do you respond to
someone who says that there's a
difference between socialism and
democratic socialism well in a sense
there is socialism is a big umbrella and
there are lots of forms of socialism
there's democratic socialism like that
which destroyed Europe there is national
socialism like that which also destroyed
Europe and there's international
socialism like that which destroyed
Russia so a lot of ways to ruin your
society a lot of varieties I don't know
do you like chocolate vanilla or
strawberry those are the differences all
under that umbrella from Chris Michael I
just watched your interview we
mr. Alsup I have never seen such a
penetrating interview and I'm 62 years
old thank you very much it's very kind
did you have a model for your
methodology if so who if not how do you
do it thanks Chris I approached that
interview we did this interview last
week with James Allsop who's a youtuber
who went with the protesters at
Charlottesville last week the pro
Charlottesville protesters in unite the
right and he was scheduled to speak
there in terms of interviewers I love
Bill Buckley I like more substantive
interviews that push people that are
combative and constructive they're not
just yelling on television but that
interview I really stressed about a
little bit because I in many ways
empathize with this kid and with people
like him because he's very young he got
famous very young he understands a
number of things correctly and he's just
gone down a dark path and has hung out
with some bad hombres to quote a great
man like the alt-right people in Richard
Spencer and it's very easy if we all
know a little learning is a dangerous
thing and if you've only read a few
texts if you've read three lines of thus
spake Zarathustra it's easy to fall down
a rabbit hole of terrible ideas and so
with that interview as hoping to press
on that in a way in which we wouldn't a
lien ate these guys who have fallen into
stupid ideas but rather show them the
flaws with their very very poor
ideologies and bring them back to
understand truth truth and beauty from
Cameron Michael I stared at the solar
eclipse without proper eye protection
and now I am a peripheral vision man I
can't see straight forward I can be
useless superpower from the sun's
radiation does your book reasons to vote
for Democrats come in Braille you are
going to be so happy to know every
single edition of reasons to vote for
Democrats is also already in Braille
ever just go to your local store pick it
up and you will catch every single word
from Greg Deer Knowles when can we
expect the Michael knows guest panel
swimsuit calendar a very good question
you know I asked before the show I asked
Cassie Dylan about this I
astha roaming and Antonio Okafor and
unfortunately they're all busy on the
shoot day but lucky for you flex is
around flex talks will be there we're
gonna have Marshall is gonna be there
Jacob arey Paul Bois so get ready it's
coming to the Daily wire store just stay
tuned it's gonna be hot it's gonna
really it's gonna be it's gonna be
something from Wayne Michael I just
heard your commentary on people from
Liberty University giving back their
degrees I think it's presumptuous to
assume it's because they're liberals and
that's why they're upset they could well
be upset because Trump is a lifelong
Democrat who isn't a conservative can't
be trusted to protect the Constitution I
do think he's doing better these days
but I can understand why some young
conservatives would feel strongly about
this and would want to see Cruz 2020
that's a lot there's a lot in that in
that mailbag question that isn't my
issue with it I don't my issue with it
isn't the Trump enos of it all my issue
with it is that these students shouldn't
be giving back degrees be-caw or
diplomas because they don't like who the
president of the university voted for
that's very stupid and very shallow in a
very shallow view of education and if
these kids perhaps they should give back
their degrees because they clearly
haven't been educated by this university
they should understand the value of a
liberal education and that political
disagreement with some administrator is
not cause to tear up the symbol of your
education and on that point my other
issue with it is it's not possible it is
a completely empty gesture if you
receive an award from some institution
or a government you can reject that and
that is a protest of whatever that
institution is doing but the university
diploma is a symbol of your education
it's a symbol of four years of your
reading books or more likely chasing
women and drinking and gambling and
staying up late you can't give that back
you can't earn in the piece of paper but
when you go to apply for a job or in the
rest of your life you will still have
had that education and so it's empty
word virtue signaling the worst of what
Millennials do and makes them look
foolish from Michael Michael that's a
great name what is something unusual or
strange about your fantastic boss Ben
Shapiro and I bet I don't know this is
Michael or Ben who wrote this that you
would like to share with the world I
would ask you what is not unusual about
bench
here then was a syndicated national
columnist at 17 he was playing violin
publicly for who was it for Larry King
when he was like 2 he's he writes about
700,000 words per day so everything I
would say maybe next question will
answer what is what is usual about what
is common about ben shapiro from Teresa
hey mister best-selling blank book
Knowles
hey Teresa if you were ever to hold
office how would you approach the issue
of abortion I would want less of it I
would try to make the law and the
judicial interpretation such that there
would be less abortion in certain
general but also there are two prongs to
this one I think conservatives fight
this issue on left-wing terms so we're
always arguing about cases of rape
incest or life of the mother
those constitute less than 1 percent of
annual abortions we always talk about
three days after an egg has been
fertilized and the left loves to use
their jørgen of zygote and blastula and
this then the other thing to refer to
these early embryos we should fight it
on the other end we should fight it
where it's clear when people are getting
sonograms and they can see babies full
babies in the in the uterus we should
say that this is wrong this is clearly
wrong this is a human life that has
nobody defending it and they can't speak
for itself and and we should do it there
as far as roe v wade is concerned story
decisis would play a role in this I once
asked Antonin Scalia about this and
whether it was possible at this point to
overturn roe v wade there is a lot of
time that has passed and the principle
of story decisis is such that you give
some credence to the time even when a
bad decision is made but some decisions
are so bad or so egregious that they
could be overturned anyway and I suppose
that's what we'll have to hope for from
forestay Michael as a fellow staunch
Catholic but also an ardent conservative
I'm troubled by some of the viewpoints
more recently espoused by the Pope and
other church leaders regarding
immigration climate change capitalism
etc join the club do you think the
Catholic Church is falling to the left
thanks this reminds me of O'Sullivan's
first law which is that all institutions
that are not explicitly conservative or
right-wing
will become left-wing over time so there
is this natural tendency for
organizations to move left luckily as
you believe and as I believe the church
is a unique institution instituted by
Christ on earth and one argument for the
catholicity of the Catholic Church of
the universality of it the the realness
of it is that it's been around for so
long it has so much weight and so much
inertia that even bad Pope's can't
change it even bad Cardinals have a
great difficulty pushing it in the other
direction so you know papal
infallibility is misunderstood the Pope
is fallible except when he's infallible
it's only been invoked a handful of
times and I have great faith that the
Catholic Church as a as a divine
institution on earth will be able to
withstand even bad Pope's and I'm not
explicitly calling out Francis but we've
had a lot of bad Pope's in the past we
have survived them the Vatican Exorcist
actually Gabriele a amore who died
recently
he said that Satan was in the Vatican
and that there were dark forces
operating we see it all the time with
obviously the sex scandal but probably
even more so the scandal with the
Vatican Bank anybody who ever tries to
reform that institution gets thrown out
the window basically and so I wouldn't
be surprised if after two of the
greatest Pope's in history two of the
greatest man of the century holding that
office that the devil would be a little
hungry to make things go crazy but I
have faith there nonetheless in the
institution and maybe the church
militant is in a purgatorial phase at
the moment but we have hope that will
come out of it on that very specific and
serious note we got to say goodbye I
will say one thing pretty soon Andrew
Clavin and I he's the father of
what's-his-name over there are going to
be releasing a little podcast that we've
just done on our own it's Drew's next
book it's his story another kingdom and
I perform it it's probably the only role
I'm ever gonna get again in Hollywood
after my blank book came out so look out
for that it's gonna be a lot of fun
another Kingdom it'll be all fiction and
really really cool and enjoy the weekend
I hope you survive and we will be back
again on Monday I'm Michael Knowles
thanks for watching this is my
Kenosha
[Music]